HAS TO DROP AND GET IN FRONT.
>> CHRIS: 19 SECONDS REMAINING.
THE SHOT CLOCK IS A SECOND AND A
HALF AHEAD OF THE GAME CLOCK.
JOKIC HAS IT.
EIGHT TO SHOOT.
WE'RE TIED 127-127.
JOKIC DOUBLES.
HE FINDS GORDON.
GORDON FOR THREE -- YES!
[ BUZZER ]
NUGGETS LEAD, 130-127.
AARON GORDON FROM THE CORNER.
1.7 REMAINING.
DID GORDON GET IT OFF IN TIME?
HE DID!
WHAT A SHOT BY AARON GORDON!
>> KATY: THAT PASS FROM NIKOLA
JOKIC AS HE'S DOUBLE TEAMED --
>> CHRIS: NIKOLA JOKIC RECORDS
HIS TENTH ASSIST.
HE'S GOT ANOTHER TRIPLE-DOUBLE.
>> KATY: IT WAS ON DAVON REED.
A TECHNICAL FOUL ON DAVON REED.
I BELIEVE IT WAS FOR BEING ON
THE COURT, THINKING THAT THE
TIME WAS OUT.
>> CHRIS: 130-128 IN OVERTIME.
1.7 REMAINING.
LUKE KENNARD.
1.7.
CLIPPERS HAVE A CHANCE FOR A
HEAP.
REGGIE JACKSON --
[ BUZZER ]
>> CHRIS: NO GOOD!
AND THE NUGGETS HAVE WON IT!
UBILITY FINISH!
THEY ARE GOING BALLISTIC IN THE
BALL!
AARON GORDON COMES UP WITH ONE
OF THE BIGGEST SHOTS OF HIS